hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game a lot of you requested
it's from round five of this year's Baku
open and I only uh got around to it now
we've been covering some tournaments
it's uh the blindfold King Grandmaster
timurgaria versus a woman International
uh Grandmaster Divya Deshmukh who uh
after finishing Baku open on a very high
note uh got her International Master
title and it's quite the game you guys
will enjoy this one uh so let's dive
straight into it so Timur has the white
pieces and he opens with Knight to F3 he
goes for the reti with Ponte D5 G3
Knight to C6 and now Pawn to D4 the
king's Indian attack with Bishop to F5
Bishop to G4 is a bit more popular but
Bishop 5 is what she goes for uh Bishop
to G2 we have castles uh sorry E6 we
have castles and now Knight to B4 going
after the C2 pawn and this is where the
game gets really interesting you're okay
this is a known position usually you'll
see night day three here but instead
Timor goes Pawn to see for now it's a
very very cool idea allowing this Knight
to see to move and sacrificing The Rook
on A1 but can it be done uh of course it
can it has been played before Knights
the C2 we have seat captures on D5 and
she grabs the full Rook Knight captures
on A1 of course now uh uh it's not going
to be easy for the Knight to get back so
he will at least win the exchange and
there are games where the captors and E6
was played for example Daniel yufa tried
it against Hans Neiman uh he uh he lost
that game but here we have Pawn to E4
it's an improvement and the D captures
an E6 line uh Bishop capture Sunny for
now D captures on E6 you cannot capture
back with the bishop now F captures and
now Knight to C3 using the bishop here
as a sort of a Tempo move now the Knight
is attacking the bishop and there are
games where Bishop to F5 was played but
she plays Bishop captures on F3 and it
is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so okay uh uh Bishop
captures on F3 is what Timor goes for
now it's interesting why not capture
with the queen and the reason why it's
interesting is that yeah you can't
really take the D4 Pawn if you take the
D4 Pawn uh then uh Rook to D1 and black
resigns that's the problem there's no
good reply for black hero if you move
the queen let's say okay you want to
defend the B7 Pawn let's say play Queen
to B6 not a problem Queen to H5 check G6
Queen to E5 and you can resign this
there's no coming back from this and
another thing after Rook to D1 you can
also play Queen to F6 sort of all for a
queen trade but then Queen capture some
B7 lets it Rook to d8 and now Bush up
the C6 with check King F7 Queen captures
and C7 check and off Goes The Rook so uh
whatever you play you're lost here so
the idea behind the uh Bishop captures
on F3 isn't that you cannot capture with
the queen uh it's just that I I I don't
know why why Timur did not capture with
the queen uh and the bishop on F3
doesn't look like uh it belongs there
but okay we have Knight to F7 6 Bishop
captures on B7 now maybe that was the
idea the bishop was not going to remain
on F3 we have rooked the B8 and now
Bishop the C6 with check we have King to
F7 and now Pawn to D5 she's on the run
with the king so of course he wants to
open up lines of attack towards the
black king so upon the E5 of course she
wants to keep the position closed uh and
the bishop to G5 now developing pinning
the Knight and also preparing to capture
the Knight on A1 uh winning back a
little bit of material so here Rook the
B4 not allowing the knights to come to
E4 Queen to E2 now guarding the E4
square and also preparing Rook captures
on A1 uh Queen the CH she unpins here
from the bishop and also prepares Queen
to G4 to offer a queen trade and okay
now you have to waste the move to
capture the Knight on A1 so Rook
captures an A1 and queen to G4 offering
a queen trade Queen captures an E5 and
now Bishop to D6 this is a very
important move it develops the bishop
prepares The Rook to come into the game
and and also it prevents moves like
Ponte D6 then you allow this diagonal to
open up and it could be very scary so
Bishop to D6 definitely a must move and
here the problem is if you move the
queen let's say queen to E3 then comes
Rook captures some B2 and okay then the
yarrow comes to B8 and you are perfectly
fine here it's uh it's a it's a great
position for black so instead uh Gareth
goes for Queen to E6 with check he
offers the queen trade Queen captures an
E6 Pawn captures King captures and now
Rook to E1 with check and now if you
count the pieces and the material on the
board uh he has four five points she has
four pawns but also he is down the
exchange but look at this now after King
to F7 we have rooked a two now guarding
the B2 Pawn Now Pawn to H6 chases away
the bishop Bishop to E3 goes after the
pawn here and now Bishop to E5 she gives
up the A7 Pawn at the mess of his Pawn
structure and then she's gonna uh go and
to collect further material so here
Bishop captures an A7 we have Bishop
campus and C3 B captures on C3 and now
Rook the C for attacking the bishop in
the C3 Pawn so Bishop to B5 and now Rook
captures in C3 and now if you look at
this position and when I checked out
this position first you can easily see
that Divia is up the exchange but uh
Timur has the bishop pair and he has the
outside past a pawn and now whenever I
see a bishop pair and then outside past
a pawn I remember the first game of the
match Bobby Fischer versus Ben Larson
from their 1971 candidates match and uh
of course you know that fisher pretty
much played every game brilliantly but
that game he sacrifices Queen for the
bishop pair in the outside pass pawn and
he just Advanced that pass Pawn to
Victory okay he also had a rook but his
King was wide in the open so
uh he he needed The Rook to defend the
king but it was the bishop pair uh that
helped escort the pawn so now when I saw
this position I immediately thought okay
of course uh uh somehow Gary will put
his Bishop on F3 to guard A8 this bishop
will come to E3 to guard A7 and the
Bishops will be excellently placed here
and he will just Advance the past pawn
and win the game but it's not as easy to
achieve this here he played Bishop to D4
attacks The Rook we have rooked the C1
check King the G2 and now rooked the d8
she attacks the bishop here Bishop to E3
and now Rook the C3 and this kind of
stops the idea because now if you try
something like Ponte four okay you wanna
reposition your Bishop start advancing
that pawn and now C6 is very annoying
and you can't uh get the setup that you
want now the bishop has nowhere to go
you have to go to A6 and now Knight
comes the D5 attacks this bishop this
bishop is in the way you're just not in
a position to start advancing that fast
Pawn so instead he played uh Rook the B2
uh now we have Knight the E4 and now uh
Bishop to E2 so of course the bishop
will now come to come to F3 or so you
might think we have King back to G8 she
wants to hide the king as far away as
possible from that Bishop pair not to
run into any nasty checks with Bishop to
F4 attacking the pawn and just Knights
the D6 blocking uh we have Bishop back
to D2 Rook to C5 and now Bishop to B4 we
have rooked the C6 and now Bishop to D1
even uh King to HH who wants to get the
king away now from the bishop pair and
now Bishop to B3 and here I I thought
this was a really weird maybe he's going
for some sort of an attacking setup he
wants to get maybe H4 H5 in completely
box the black the black king and use the
rook and the bishop pair to constantly
create threads and then Advance the pass
Pawn uh which okay uh obviously you can
do it that way too I just thought that
uh probably uh because of that game
fisher versus Larson I always think that
the bishop belongs the bishop perfilons
and these diagonals and then you just
Advance the pawn on but okay here we
have Knight to F5 Ponte H4 and now Rook
to B8 putting pressure on that Bishop uh
so Pawn to A3 defending and now Rook C
to B6 now she's threatening Fantasy 5 to
win material here and he plays Bishop to
C2 he attacks the Knight here but uh
this uh is not as great as it seems feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the absolute best move for Divya
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting the
Free Pawn and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on H4 there are also Knight
captures on G3 can be played she decided
to go for the H4 Pawn messes up white
spawn structure on the king side
completely so it makes sense G counters
and now Pawn to C5 uh winning more
material we have King the G3 of course
you cannot move because Rook captures on
B2 so King to G3 C captures mb4 Rook
captures with Rook captures eight
captures and now Rook captures on B4 and
now she's just up the exchange and if
this is played precisely you should be
able to win this we have Pawn to F4 now
um
uh well teamwork's Last Hope is that
this can be uh maybe transformed into
some sort of an impenetrable Castle but
it is very unlikely we are Keen to G8
Ponte H5 and now King the F7 with King
to G4 King to E6 and now Bishop to H7
and now his idea is that of course the
king cannot approach the pawn if the
king cannot approach the pawn then it's
a draw you can never push because of
captures if you can't uh approach the
pawn uh that means that it should be
some sort of a castle the problem is
King can go around and at some point go
behind the pawn and The Rook will be
used to chase away the white king from
the pawn so that will be her plan we
have rooked the B8 now comes Bishop to
E4 and The Rook to f8 uh we have King
the F3 uh the problem with just
repeating moves with the bishop and I'm
sure you guys were thinking of this too
why not just move the bishop back and
forth is that you can play King to D5
and after let's say Bishop to F5 you
will play King to D for the uh the the
kind of the strategy we discussed Bishop
to H7 King to E3 and after Bishop to F5
black merely has to waste the move let's
say Rook to F7 or Rook F6 doesn't really
matter and now white is in tukwang you
will have to make some sort of a weird
move and then Rook captures on F4
happens and then uh you or you just
collected the rest of material so here
King the F3 was played uh and now comes
King to D6 uh with King to E3 Rook to B8
we have Bishop to G6 and now Rook the B4
uh just give me a second
I just had to answer a quick message now
so he wrote the B4 with Bishop to F7 and
now King the C5 now she has to bring the
King around with Bishop to G8 uh Rook to
B8 attacks the bishop in Bishop to H7
and now Rook the E8 with check we have
King to D3 he's trying to box uh out the
the black king not allow him to
get anywhere near that pawn but of
course it is the Unstoppable King the D5
with Bishop to G6 now comes Rook to E7
with Bishop to H7 King to C5 Bishop to
G8 and now we have Rook the E8 attacking
the bishop and here a team will play
Bishop to F7 he sort of ran into a you
know a winning one move and she played
Rook to f8 and he was in this position
on move 59 at the Timur Gareth resigned
in the game as there is nothing more to
be done once he moves the bishop of
course through captures on F4 and now
black is completely winning but the very
interesting thing is uh how does uh how
does she win if he does not play Bishop
to F7 let's say he just continues with
uh Bishop H7 I mean that that's the
whole idea behind the castle or behind
the Fortress that uh yeah the black can
never reach the pawn the idea is once uh
black king goes behind let's say you you
push the the white king away with checks
King C3 King E4 King to D2 King F3 Rook
to A8 you will be able to chase away the
white king from the pawn like the king
E4 rookie for check King F3 King the E1
Bishop H7 you have to waste moves Rook
E3 checking E4 King F2 and now the white
King has to go up the board or you're
gonna waste moves with the bishop let's
say Bishop to G8 King G3 and now once
you touch uh once the king is touching
the pawn now it's merely a matter of
check because the pawn is on a dark
Square so you know you can't afford that
you have to push it to a light square
but still doesn't matter Rook F3 okay
the bishop defends the pawn you waste
the move a king moves you attack the
pawn now now you are you're attacking
the pawn and after the bishop moves you
will simply play Rook to F4 and now uh
again not much to be done the king will
move you will play another a move
wasting idea after King T5 rookie one
check and after the king moves you will
just force the king away now you win the
E5 square and after the king moves
doesn't really matter where you it
doesn't have to run into check you will
still play Rook to E5 and you will give
up The Rook for the bishop of course the
white cannot accept this because the
king opponent is very much winning I
mean you're going to win the pawn as
well so you're gonna have to play
something else like King D6 but now you
just play check King moves and now you
will pick up the bishop you don't want
to play this if you play Rook captures
on g6h captures and try this then it's a
draw because after King to fate the
white also picks up the pawn and gets
his Pawn to become a queen but after
King to G5 there's no escaping this you
will play uh something like Bishop here
uh then uh the uh The Rook will come to
F5 and then you will again try to give
up your Rook for the pawn Rook captures
on H5 and it doesn't matter what what
what white plays it's still completely
winning
so a very very exciting idea uh Timur
tried to get her out of her Comfort Zone
by going for this uh a very tricky line
like I said once the Night Comes to B4
ninth day three is pretty much an
automatic in this position he tried to
get an interesting position with C4
which he absolutely did I mean this is a
beautiful position look at this this is
move 10 already there's a rook missing
on A1 uh so definitely an exciting game
but she played it perfectly and uh you
know later on in in a pretty much uh
what should have been an equal end game
as she completely outplayed him and yeah
I I don't know I still feel that the
Bishops belonged on these diagonals it
was just very very hard to get that pawn
uh of the board because as soon as you
play something like A4 Rook the A3 would
come and come and then you would have
problems uh crossing the A5 Square uh
but if he somehow somehow got to the
pawn all the way there then the bishop
pair would be unstoppable
so a very interesting game a big
congratulations to Divya on uh receiving
her International Master title hope you
guys enjoyed this game I would like to
thank masi and Elsa agrovision reptiles
YouTube uh Blake Turner and Peter Marino
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and everything else that happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day